some of them are Engineers some of them
have degrees I think there's someone who
even wrote a book called The Big Bang
never happened Eric Lerner who I even
bought his book I shouldn't have done it
but I did it he had one piece of
evidence was we hadn't found the small
variations in the intensity of the
microwave background that need to be
there to explain galaxies and what was
funny about this book is it literally
written 6 months before those variations
were discovered and so it's really easy
to throw mud and get a headline the Big
B never happened you know if I said oh
the Big Bang happened we found another
piece of evidence for it and I go to the
editor of San Diego Union paper can I
get that on the front page N I don't
think so I have someone who will say the
Big Bang never happened can I get that
on the front page oh
yeah